[Music]
and welcome to Hannity and tonight we
are less than 24 hours away from our
exclusive town hall with former
president Donald J Trump in Davenport
Iowa by the way if you'd like to join us
or attend you can sign up on hannity.com
it is for free tickets are free anyway
and poll after poll as of now president
Trump is now beating Joe Biden in a
hypothetical rematch uh by pretty
significant margin at this point many
polls showing it one key reason for the
numbers while Trump's actually willing
and able to participate in a real town
hall and passionately an answer
important questions of our time Biden
meanwhile he can barely answer two or
three pre-selected questions without
imploding now sadly the president's
mental condition is likely going to get
worse not better as it stands now Joe is
not doing well over the weekend he
looked really really bad yet again
despite a very light workload the
president still managed to struggle
mightily take a look the brother's bound
made it all seem effortless and almost
magical they described it as quote we'll
be walking down the street together and
we'll simultaneously began to sing the
same song and the same key God love you
Billy I tell you that's incredible
before I travel from the Bronx to change
the and by the way with other movies and
movies she's earned a golden glob and a
prime time enemy
enemy that's
me prime time ammy and after his marks
Joe had trouble yet again attempting to
step away from a Podium he looked Dazed
and Confused shuffled his feet until his
wife was able to coax him in the right
direction yet again somebody needs to
help him just like at the Tomb of the
you know Unknown Soldier Here We Go
Again Biden's only going to get worse
from here unfortunately yeah it tends to
get worse worse and worse when you have
cognitive decline it is degenerative now
his re-election bid defies all logic I
cannot think of a public appearance that
your president has made now in months
where he's not mumbling stumbling
bumbling in his speech and or dazed and
confused about where to go and what to
do next and tonight whether Biden
realizes it or not he has a huge problem
on the horizon as a matter of fact many
problems Fox News has confirmed house
Republican leaders they will most likely
push forward with a vote to initiate an
impeachment inquiry next week now this
after Biden has once again been caught
in aive you might recall take a look Mr
Vice President how many times have you
ever spoken to your son about his
overseas business dealings I have never
spoken to my son about his overseas
business dealings I have never discussed
with my son or my brother or anyone else
anything having to do with their
businesses period And what I will do is
the same thing we did and our
Administration there will be an absolute
wall between personal and private uh and
and the government do you stand by your
statement that you did not discuss any
of your son's overseas business yes I
stand by that statement now according to
newly unearth Bank record subpoenaed by
the house oversight committee chairman
James comr not only did Joe Biden
discuss his son's business ventures but
he also received direct payments from
one of Hunter's corporations now Hunter
Biden's attorneys claim while their
client was was merely paying his father
back for a truck that Hunter financed
but keep in mind that these 2018
payments were not made from Hunter's
personal account instead one of Hunter's
many llc's deposited the money into
Joe's account an account used to conduct
business in China so why did Hunter pay
uh his father from a business account
and why did Joe lie about ever
discussing business foreign business
deals with his son his brother or
anybody for for that matter now last
month coma revealed two very unusual
checks to Joe Biden from his brother
also purporting to be loan repayments
now we've also long reported texts and
emails from Hunter complaining about
having to Fork over half his income to
Pops another email from Hunter's
business partner discussing setting
aside 10% for the big guy old Tony
balinsky told us who the big guy was
another document revealing that Joe
Biden used his son's Wells Fargo account
to pay bills and of course there are
photographs and text messages and emails
and eyewitness accounts detailing when
Vice President Biden had his meetings
his phone calls his letters and even
dinners Cafe Milano with Hunter's
foreign Partners now these are not
Business Leaders or Wall Street
Executives instead Hunter and other
Biden family members they were raking in
massive amounts of money tens of
millions of dollars from sketchy
oligarchs well-connected foreign
Nationals and in some of our country's
biggest geopolitical foes like Russia oh
China Ukraine Romania Kazakhstan you
name it and other countries honor Biden
who admittedly at the time was
struggling with addiction had no
relevant experience at all with Finance
or in the gas coal and energy industry
getting paid Millions for what now
that's the 20 plus million doll question
isn't it as Sun's former business
partner Deon marcher stated they were
buying access to the Biden brand and
possible influence over US policy that
could well could some maybe think about
calling that potentially maybe uh needs
to be investigated as bribery let's look
at article two section four of our
constitution the president the vice
president and all civil officers of the
United States shall be removed from
office on impeachment for and conviction
of treason bribery and other high crimes
and misdemeanors now here's just one
example of what we're talking about
according to a US Senate committee on
homeland security and governmental
Affairs report in 2014 when Joe Biden
was vice president Hunter Biden received
a 3.5 million wire transfer from a woman
former first lady of Moscow Elena
batarina she's also a Russian oligarch
our husband yeah was the mayor of Moscow
Bina was known as you know the first
lady of Moscow by the way she wasn't
sanctioned with many other Russian
oligarchs after the invasion of Ukraine
I'm sure just a coincidence and was one
of the wealthiest people in Russia deep
ties to Vladimir Putin himself and yet
following Russia's invasion of Ukraine
the first lady of Moscow was one of the
few oligarchs not targeted by Joe
Biden's sanctions this reeks of
corruption remember remember Congress
has a sworn duty to uphold the US
Constitution and check the executive
branch and now there is more than enough
evidence for a trial uh for once in his
life Joe Biden he's got to be held
accountable if Democrats truly believe
that foreign interference is a serious
threat like they've been lecturing us
over and over again that Russia
collusion is a clear and present danger
then they will join with Republicans
they will hold Biden's feet to the fire
otherwise all of their righteous
indignation has been nothing but well
frankly show hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else